(Svp, si vous savez pas écrire, faites pas les sous-titres) / Ok on est parés
Ok ! Ok on est parés
Quel intro veux-tu faire ?
Ha non ! Fallait pas me dire ça !
Tu as tout gâché Nyo !
Putain !
Quel intro tu veux faire, tu montres aux gens que j'suis une merde en disant ça ! (Pleure)
Ne pleure pas Nyo !
Les amis souvenez-vous avec Nyo la dernière fois, on avait créé des monstruosités
On avait créé des chats très bizarres
Mais aussi des sacs à main et des chaussures
Et des chaussures, oui c'était nul à ce point
Oui si tu te posais la question
Alors, p'tite info, Nyo est en lendemain de soirée
Hoo , mais ça va bien se passer
Oui ça va très bien , c'est la fête , tend moi ta nuque
*tape* Hop c'est bon , gouaaaaah , ça va mieux c'est bon il est remis sur pattes
La bonne nouvelle du jour c'est qu'aujourd'hui y'a la même chose qui est sorti
Mais avec des visages
C'est à dire que là on va dessiner des visages et ça va générer à partir de 200 photos j'crois
La base donnée , c'est un truc du genre , ça va mixer les photos pour faire l'image qu'on a dessiné
Un exemple ci-contre !
Hein ? que tu viens de dessiner
Que je viens de dessiner ,  moi même bien sûr merci (petit test ) , nan mais c'est bien de le soulever parce que  après les gens
(Ouais mais c'est important) , la dernière fois j'ai ( y'a des doutes) , voilà merci
Qui commence ?
Ok j'ai un jeu pour nous départager
Celui qui fait tourner ce hand-spinner le plus longtemps
6 minutes plus tard
On va changer de jeux (Rires)
Honneur aux invités ( Ho c'est gentil )
Vas y fais nous rêver
(J'vais tenter un truc) , fais un visage j'pense on commence ( assez classique)  classique
Ce qui faut savoir c'est que l'interface pour dessiner est absolument ignoble
(Ouais , pour ma défense ) c'est dégueulasse
C'est pas précis voila
Si ce nez par exemple ressemble au nez de Maxenss
C'est parce que le ( C'est un portrait de Maxenss) (Rires)
(Rires)
Attends mais t'as fait un truc trop bien !
Putain Nyo ! Je savais que j'aurais pas dû te faire commencer
(Ouais bah écoute c'est bon ) Ok tu t'en vas pour de vrai cette fois ! Nyo !
C'était une manière de te faire arrêter de dessiner (ok) est ce que tu es prêt ?
(Rires) Haaaaaaaan !
Mec pourquoi , j'suis déçu parce que
(Le bas est stylé ) le bas est trop bien !
(Le bas est cool ) le bas est trop bien !
Mais le haut est moins bien
Moi j'pense , j'peux te dire un truc , le prend pas mal
J'pense juste , tu sais pas dessiner
(C'est vrai ) heu un moment faut voila il faut
(Bah écoute j'essaye)
Nan mais voilà faut remettre le stylo entre les mains de voilà bon
Bon alors j'vais dessiner comme quand j'étais petit ( ok )
Là c'est moi
Ho c'est toi ! c'est toi en lendemain de soirée
(C'est vrai c'est moi ) He ! Mec
Mec , mec (franchement j'trouve ça)
Haaaaaa ! ( Ha ha ha ! )
Haaaaaaa ! tssseeeeu
haa ( en vrai ) c'est dégueulasse !
J'suis sur et certain que j'ai déjà vu des trucs comme ça dans des expo d'arts modernes chelou
Nan mec pour de vrai , la c'est terrifiant par contre
Huuuu !
Clear clear clear clear clear !
C'est bon
Bon allez
A toi , (ok)
Peut-être une femme ça passe mieux ? J'sais pas
(Heuuuuuu)
(On va essayer genre ) Peut être que ce jeu est sexiste ? ( genre de profil)
(Moi j'trouve beaucoup plus dur de dessiner des femmes )
C'est vrai ? ( heu ouais parce que genre heuu j'sais pas ) tu es officiellement sexiste
(Nan bah non ) C'est trop tard ( Je *soupire )
Une femme c'est élégant ,  ( mais c'est ça ) c'est beau
( C'est pour ça c'est plus dur ) C'est heu homogène tu vois c'est vraiment
C'est les courbes tout est dans les courbes
(Les hommes c'est ) est ce que ( les hommes c'est des carrés tu vois ?) est-ce qu'on est hétéro là actuellement Ha ha ! Mais c'est vrai que ( Les femmes !  oui ? )
Ha tu as niqué l'ambiance ( pardon ) c'est pas grave ( pardon pardon ) nan mais mec
J'espère tellement franchement tu mérites tellement qu'il se mette ( Ha ha ! ) de ouf ( ok ) ok ( on tente )
Heu ( dommage ) naaaaaan y'a pas assez de traits rajoute des traits rajoute des traits
( nan et ça la ) ferme les cheveux , ferme les cheveux , rajoute des traits de cheveux qu'il y'a la
( Ha noon ) En fait , attend ( c'est ça là ) j'pense en fait à mon avis faut
*clique* dessiner autre chose ( Rires) Heuu
He mec j'peux tenter un truc ?
Si c'est encore un jeu de mots à la con comme l'autre fois
Nan nan nan , c'est juste faire un smiley
(Haaa) et la
Haaaaaaaaaaaa!
Haaa! ( Qu'est ce que c'est que ça ? )
Damn it ,  c'est quand même pas loin d'être le meilleur qu'on ai fait donc heuu
Attend j'vais essayer aussi un truc , un smiley un peu plus simple genre cartoon
Il va vraiment être tout petit
(Rires) heu fait
Et fait un visage hyper large t'sais ( Rires)
(Rires) une forme de fraise un peu ( rires)
(Rires) jamais une fraise n'a été si vilaine
(Rires) Attention !
Hooooooo mec !
( Alors les yeux ça va mais les cheveux ) les cheveux regarde !
(Putain les cheveux ) Yann Barthès
Yann Barthès ( Yann si tu regardes cette vidéo)
C'est tes veuches , c'est pas ton sourire
(Nan ) Ho quoi que
Oh on n'est pas loin
T'sais quand il dit bienvenue dans le Quotidien il a un peu... Ok
T'es prêt ? (Oui) 23 minutes plus tard
Pourquoi j'fais une fraise ( Rires) y'a une malédiction , y'a une malédiction
Dans ce studio
J'aime les fruits !!
( Juste une question ) Ouais.. ( c'est une femme ou un homme ? )
C'est une chose
HOOOOOOO pas mal pas mal pas mal !
Hee Kim Jong Un
Kim Jong Un ( un peu ouais ) mec mec mec
Par contre il a un cocard
(C'est comme Maxenss ) Oui il s'est fait tabasser
Et au portique il a oublié de retirer le couteau du sac
Et ça l'a tabassé
Nan mais c'est vrai , he mais mec !
J'ai là là je , si j'puis me permettre
J'pense que là j'ai gagné actuellement
Actuellement ( mais à chaque fois ) mais parce qu'en fait j'pense c'est fait pour ceux qui dessinent très très mal , et vue que t'es un vrai artiste Nyo
Ca marche pas avec toi..(Arrête) *en chuchotant* rassurez toujours votre ami pour les garder , toujours
Allez vas-y à toi
(J'sais pas quoi faire , qu'est ce que je fais ? ) franchement frère
Tu fais Iron Man ( Rires)
Musique d'action
Iron man ?
Hoooooo c'est ouff !
C'est le Iron Man humain !
Mais ouais !
Mais mec c'est parfaitement ça !
(Putain c'est stylé ) c'est génial ! ( c'est grave stylé )
Heu stylé j'pense pas que ce soit..
(Oui enfin j'veux dire  ) C'est funny , c'est funny ( j'lui ferais pas un câlin quoi )
C'est un triangle , on dirait vraiment qu'on à mis le masque sous la peau d'un mec , c'est très fort
Alors la ( un peu degueu mais c'est stylé ) j'pense tu passes peut être devant moi Ha ouais ouais baaaah oooooh baaah oh baaah boon !
Ok... Antoine Daniel
(Ok) 72 minutes plus tard
Bon on est d'accord ça n'a plus rien d'Antoine Daniel
Oooh le matin..
Là je sens ça va juste donner une boule de poils
Ooooooh ! Antoine Daniel ! ( direct )
( c'est.. Bah à part qu'il à un petit épi sur le coté moi j'trouve ça plutôt stylé )
Attends j'ai envie de
Hooo Ouiiiii!!!
Oui le hand-spinner humain !!!!
Ouiii !
On est pas Haaa il a des cheveux au bout de chaque hoo c'est incroyable
(On peut dire , on dirait des teubs un peu..) Haa c'est vrai on dirait un peu des..
(Ouais un peu des) Ha ouaiiis.. ( bah surtout baah ouais heu )
Attends j'fais un test au pire on retirera au montage ( Oui faut censurer tout ça )
(Rires)
Haaaaaa haaaa ! Et attend mec regarde regarde
Aaah.. ( Ha bah la pour le coup j'suis désolé mais )
(Rires) c'est bien mais il est chelou
(Rires)
(Rires) Haaan qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de faire ?!
Et voila c'est la fin de cette vidéo merci d'avoir regardé
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu !
Merci Nyo d'être venu
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner à sa chaine comme d'habitude
Comme tous les gens qui passent dans mes vidéos
Allez voir leurs chaines ça leurs fera extrêmement plaisir !
Allez à bientôt les amis portez-vous bien ! (Tchao ! ) Moi je m'en vais
Tu viens frère ou? ( Ho pardon ! )